now you can argue we shouldn't have been
there in the first place and if we want
to get out we can just get out I think
those are perfectly legit arguments to
have but I think there's also a legit
argument to have if you break it do you
have any responsibility to fix it all
right everybody a little impromptu
direct message today as you probably
heard Trump announced yesterday that he
is pulling our troops out of Syria now
this basically seems like it should come
off as a positive thing but I don't know
if you know about this but we live in a
very polarized political world these
days and often people who would have
said one thing three years ago are
saying very different things these days
and it's just such a freaking mess
especially online where everyone
pretends they're an expert and
everything everyone who got everything
wrong five years ago ten years ago knows
exactly how to do everything now people
that were the architects of the Iraq war
george w bush's iraq war which most
people would agree was a mistake or at
least a foreign policy blunder are now
saying exactly what we should do this
time in syria so I just wanted to back
up clean up a little bit of this I am
obviously me myself not an absolute
foreign policy expert but I want to just
lay out a little bit of the chronology
of what happened and just sort of what
potentially our responsibilities are for
the region if we have any and just see
how this sort of fits in the larger
context of political conversations that
we've been having on this show so first
off I just want to be very very clear
that about five years ago when we went
into Syria in the first place and you
may remember this is when every day on
YouTube there was another horrific Isis
video and beheadings and burning human
beings alive and just beyond awful stuff
I mean I'm sure you saw the videos I saw
them just horrific stuff that Isis was
doing that we decided that well
basically Obama was president at the
time and basically he laid out a red
line that if Assad used gas on his own
people that or chemical weapons on his
own people that we were going to go into
Syria that happened and then we didn't
go in
and then there was this constant
question of who are actually the good
guys are the good guys the rebels who
were fighting Assad then there's Isis
Assad's attacking some of these people
and then there are also the Kurds I'll
get more into that in just a sec but I
just want to be very clear that about
five years ago when this was all
happening and I was a big lefty I was a
progressive I was on The Young Turks
Network you can find videos multiple
videos of me saying that I did not want
America to be involved at all my feeling
was that after several blunders that
we've made in the region that sometimes
other countries have to step in and do
things so if Syria is a big freakin mess
and there's a and there's a humanitarian
crisis there well that some of the
countries on their borders like Saudi
Arabia like Turkey are gonna have to
step in and figure out how to help
people and and that we can't always do
everything if anything I would have been
for some sort of minor I think this is
exactly what I said I would have been
for some sort of minor thing where it
wouldn't have been a military
intervention but some sort of
humanitarian corridor where we would
have had we would have helped secure
like a safe area for for refugees within
the country itself but that's it I
didn't want to go in it's really weird
now because now you're seeing plenty of
people who did want to go in now saying
we can't leave and it's like then what
happened to all of the people who are
anti-war there used to be this really
strong anti-war left and one other thing
that Trump has done is that whenever
Trump says anything the people that hate
him automatically take the reverse
position so Trump says and he ran on
this I don't want war we can't be the
world's police all of those things most
of which especially from my libertarian
side I agree with well then we're
pulling out and then people are saying
well no now we're it's gonna go to hell
in a handbasket and we can't pull out
and all that other stuff knowing full
well that for the people on the Left if
this was Obama or a Democrat president
you'd be all about pulling out I'm
trying not to make a pullout joke there
but that that's sort of where we're at
with that now there's some interesting
things here because the libertarians
right now are very very for this move
not every libertarian but generally
speaking libertarians are for this
because they don't want us using our
foreign power overseas right they have
more of an isolationist policy now I
generally agree with that but the
question is once we've done something
once we've gone into a country
and and done things do we have any
responsibility to stay there and make
sure that there's a peaceful transition
to whatever comes next so you could look
at this in a context of Iraq now most
people would agree not everybody but
most people would agree that the Iraq
war was a mistake as I said before that
being said it after a certain period of
time it actually started to work Iraq
was having free and fair elections you
may remember those videos of people with
paint on their thumbs that had finally
voted then Obama came in he ran Barry
against the Iraq war right that was
actually one of the things that
separated him from Hillary were the
first time that Obama was running he was
saying we've got to get out now Hillary
was saying we have to have they'll take
a little more time Obama kept his
promise we pulled out immediately they
set a date they pulled out and basically
since then in Iraq has collapsed because
we didn't have enough of the machinery
on the ground to facilitate them
furthering democracy now you can argue
we shouldn't have been there in the
first place and if we want to get out we
can just get out I think those are
perfectly legit arguments to have but I
think that's also a legit argument to
have if you break it do you have any
responsibility to fix it that's sort of
what we're in in Syria right now because
we went in and I think it was whether we
were supposed to be there for 30 days so
whether we were supposed to go in or not
or should have gone in or not it was
supposed to be this limited engagement
which by the way is another reason that
we need to start actually paying
attention to the Constitution and
separation of powers when it comes to
waging war and this is something that
both administration's don't do at all
both administration's both parties don't
do it all regardless of the
administration so for example Barack
Obama went into Libya I mean that's
another one and they didn't want to call
it a war cuz he didn't want to get
congressional authority so they called
it a kinetic military action I had never
heard that phrase before and most people
hadn't heard that phrase before we
basically totally destabilized Libya not
the Qaddafi was any great person and now
what's happening in Libya for these last
couple years it's basically chaos and we
don't even talk about it
that's something Obama did Trump's now
saying we've got to get out but now the
question is this okay if you're if
you're saying America first or we want
to have more of an isolationist policy
or we can't be the world's police again
I'm totally sympathetic to all of those
views I actually
I think there's a lot of legitimacy to
it it's well what is going to happen to
Syria when we leave and more
specifically it's not Syria it's the
Kurds so the Kurds are a true ethnic
minority that live in Syria they live in
Iraq they live in Turkey these are
people who should have a state whether
it has to be carved out of all three of
those countries and that that's been the
negotiation for years
believe it or not there's a there's a
video of Joe Biden when he was running
back against Barack Obama the first time
in the Democratic primary where Biden
talks about having to carve up some of
those countries to give the Kurds a
state anyway the Kurds have been a major
ally of ours they are the ones that were
on the ground fighting Isis they
generally speaking believe in Western
values and in freedom there are
wonderful videos of women that were
enslaved by Isis that get rescued
by the Kurds and you can see them
ripping off the veils and all of those
things the question now is are we
abandoning the Kurds who we've armed by
the way and all sorts of stuff are we
now abandoning them and now just gonna
let Turkey slaughter them and erdowan
and in Turkey is an Islamist he will
have no problem killing as many Kurds as
he wants to as he's done in the past and
his turkey really our ally were both in
NATO but what actual common values do we
share with Turkey and its current
incarnation I'm not really sure so while
I see the the the left basically saying
we can't leave just because they hate
Trump so that doesn't seem to make any
sense to me right because if it was a
Democratic president you'd all be about
getting out and the left is supposed to
be anti-war now I see the libertarians
going we've got to get the hell out of
there but just doing that without having
any sort of responsibility for what
you've created
ooh Siri just turned on in the middle of
this by herself my apologies I couldn't
hear what you said
did I say Syria and she thought it was
Syria okay that's weird anyway so you've
got the the anti-war left that is sort
of disappeared because they just want to
go against Trump and Trump wants out
you've got the libertarians basically
saying we shouldn't have been there in
the first place we gotta go regardless
of the consequences
and then you've got say maybe the more
neo cons or conservatives saying we
should have went or even if we shouldn't
have went in the first place or
shouldn't have gone
in the first place we do have some
responsibility to make sure that
basically the Kurds don't get
slaughtered
I think the these are all interesting
arguments to have I fall more on the
side that we have got to we have to
leave right we can't just be there
forever I like sort of what I think
Trump actually tweeted this I'm gonna
pull it up for just a sec there was
something that actually did did make
sense there so a couple things that
Trump said he said we were supposed to
be there for for 30 days and with no aim
in sight I said I was going to end these
things that seems legit then here's this
is this is quite a tweet by Trump as I
have stated strongly before and just to
reiterate if turkey does anything that I
in my great and unmatched wisdom
consider to be off-limits I will totally
destroy and obliterate the economy of
Turkey I've done before.i
in my great and unmatched wisdom all
right so putting it putting aside
Trump's premiere trolling there it's
it's a obviously a nutty statement but
what he's saying is Turkey we're gonna
leave if you start killing the Kurds and
invading Syria to kill more of them or
take land or something like that we will
do something so that basically seems
right again it's giving too much power
to the executive branch right it's
giving too much power to the
presidential branch this should be done
by Congress and all right so that that's
sort of where we're at if you want more
on this check out I did an interview a
couple years ago with by on Sami Abdul
Rahman she is the KRG the Kurdish
regional government rep to the United
States she talks really about the
history of the Kurds and all that this
is just a brief very quick overview but
I wanted to clean up a little bit of
this and just talk a little bit more
about sort of the philosophical pieces
behind why everyone's arguing all the
time about this thank you for watching
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell